It's more common than breast cancer.
It has over 150 different symptoms associated with it.
What is it?
Lyme disease.
My wife nearly lost her life to chronic Lyme disease.
That changed everything.
That's why I'm so passionate about this subject.
I'm Dr. J. Davidson.
After doing three consecutive chronic Lyme disease summits
with over 100 different interviews,
I get asked all the time, Dr. J,
what do I need to know about Lyme disease?
Well, I've put it all together in one event,
the best of the best out there,
including Dr. Mercola, Dr. Klinghark, Dr. Todd Watts,
Dr. Jill Carnahan, Dr. Horowitz, Dr. Cowden,
Dr. Christine Schaffner, even my wife, Dr. Heather Davidson.
To bring you the solutions that you have not been told,
get registered today for this free event,
the best of the chronic Lyme disease summit,
and I'll see you inside.